天啊 台灣股市今天由低到高
拉了快1000點 1天
台股拉了快1000點
代表的是什麼
可以樂觀了嗎
還是這是有陷阱
還是這是哲哲說的
不會打第二隻腳
不會破40000點了
你趕快拉回就買
第二個 可是量能依舊不到7000億
怎麼還可以反彈
散戶何時回歸
第三個 貨幣供給死亡交叉
什麼叫貨幣供給死亡交叉
投資朋友只有聽過
技術線型的死亡交叉
怎麼會有貨幣供給的死亡交叉
哲哲今天稍微跟你講一下
什麼叫貨幣供給死亡交叉
這個對股市的動能
是不是一個致命一擊呢
今天所有的飆股介紹
通通在今天我們榮耀華爾街
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
應該說140萬粉絲的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
今天台灣股市來看一下
拉了快千點翻紅
這真的很誇張
我們來看一下 畫面給我
這樣拉耶
你們想過嗎 這是大盤
這樣拉啦 扯不扯
從44000拉到天邊去了
這麼誇張 這麼抖
從44000一路拉起來
44000這樣狂拉啦
這個行情太扯了啦
怎麼會這樣
我早就跟大家講了
40000點不會破
現在不只40000點不會破
44000就有買盤
那很多人覺得說
哲哲這個反彈沒有量
你要這樣想
就是因為現在量縮
所以好拉抬台股
代表逢低的時候有人買進
我再講一件事情
這個AI是百年大計
不是忌諱的忌
你們10年後會發現到
滿街的自駕車
希望台灣趕快自駕車開放
拜託 台灣的交通部趕快開放
你們就知道投資AI是對的
10年後跟現在
你們從現在開始記得我的預告
10年後很多的職業會消失
會大幅度減少
駕駛 路上的計程車
還有我講的客服人員
很多的職業
很多 尤其行政的
公司內部的簡化
非常多的職業會減少
這樣怎麼辦
都是因為AI取代了
律師不會減少
可是律師的助理
法律助理也會減少
很多職業都會減少
就是因為AI的變化
而你利用這個AI的變化
第一個可以明哲保身
你的工作
不管他有沒有失去
你可以利用投資幫自己買保險
總比買那些壽險
買那些什麼保險來的好很多
聽得懂嗎
投資朋友 這是44000
奧特曼也跟你講了
其實這樣子的進步反而是對的
所以我要講的是說
其實你要了解哲哲看的未來
我每次看到AI圖就是
像我現在什麼東西
我都用Gemini
你知道嗎
什麼東西我都用Gemini
很多商業的秘密
我跟大家講
我看到這個圖 來看一下
這是哲哲的圖
你再也買不到600塊的台積電
你知道嗎
那時候我買台積電買600元
我說600元台積電 我叫會員買
600元以下就是老天爺送給你的禮物
這是名言喔
我足足被笑了半年
接下來我笑那些人笑了好幾年
因為台積電從2022年
300多元 380元
然後一下漲600元
漲到700元
2022年到現在也才3 4年而已
800 900 1000
1100 1200 1300
1400 1500有沒有看到
1600 1700 2000
這變成哲哲的名言
你去搜尋一下
哲哲 600元台積電
一堆哲哲的梗圖
我就是站在時代的前端
我是全台灣數一數二
第一個成立LINE的分析師
也是第一個成立TG的分析師
我也很早 也是數一數二
成立個人的YouTube頻道分析師
我都在時代的前端
你懂嗎 走在時代前端
我也是第一個用AI告訴你
AI股會漲一整年的
你要相信我看到的未來好不好
這10年以後變化很多
很多癌症會克服了
你看 最近跟你講
很多網紅跟你講莫德納的故事
可以個人化疫苗
個人化疫苗是預防你的癌症
二期 三期都不必怕
以前根本就是
三期以後根本就是等死了
現在不一定
所以我告訴你
這些AI怎麼不會有人投資
那為什麼最近看起來
美債看起來要崩了 又沒有崩
其實我有沒有跟大家講
這些東西我都講過
我們先講總體經濟再講股票
先講股票也沒關係
你看今天一堆股票 台勝科也好
是不是拉尾盤
2344華邦電是不是拉尾盤
是不是很扯
狂拉啊 各位
你看華邦電 有沒有看到
狂拉尾盤 還有呢
3532台勝科 狂拉
2327國巨
逢低的時候我就一直叫人家加碼
不要搞錯啊
然後有人講國巨哲哲怎麼辦
你們搞不清楚
國巨讓你們賠錢不是哲哲耶
我400多元買耶
500多元買耶
一堆人叫你買1200耶
不要搞錯我是白衣騎士
我是來救你的
你看拉回不買
不就600元台積電 你等於笑哲哲
不要傻了 誰笑誰
誰笑誰 懂不懂
這個跟大家講的
你看哲哲都預告在前面了
再講一件事
我的嘴巴 我不說垃圾話
我在台灣股市跌破4萬點
還在愛你們的
等一下喔 畫面給我
等一下 好 這邊
4萬點有沒有看到
破4萬點的時候
還是在這邊買的
只有我公開買1億台灣50
現在還是賺1000多萬啦
真的一定要等到5萬點
你才看到我看到的未來嗎
你們要想一件事情
哲哲好紅
哲哲講話好幽默
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
命一條 衝就對了
你覺得我好有梗喔
不是 我不是這個才紅的
我是因為我抓了很多低點啦
不然這100多萬粉絲
140萬粉絲耶
拜託一下 你看有電視台捧我嗎
沒有 因為我說老實話
我不需要靠人家
這樣講雖然很討厭 我不需要
我喜歡靠我自己
來 140萬訂閱者
現在直播人數4000多人
你們都遲到
我遲到就算了 你們也遲到
趕快進來啦
昨天都7 8000人
國巨多少可以攤平
平均價在1000
你在1000的 你不來找我
你那個很難解套
我們不是有做圖片嗎
看助理要不要再給我
你們不要開玩笑好不好 國巨啦
你有國巨你還不來找我 真的是喔
你又不找我 你又不攤平
國巨1000元怎麼逃
一堆人從這邊到這邊
加了30萬人
你想也知道到
到了1000元你這邊30萬人
全部都有可能
至少賣個20萬人耶
你覺得賣20萬人會多大的賣壓
他一定反覆震盪
所以1000元以上的國巨
不會這麼快就上去了好不好
你用屁股 用膝蓋想
膝蓋
你用膝蓋想就知道了
那不可能的啦
不要騙自己
你有那些高檔套牢的
只有哲哲能救你 趕快來找我
好不好 趕快來找我
好不好 OK嗎 真的
我的籌碼面告訴你很清楚了
都反覆震盪好不好 OK
真的棒 愛你喔
我也愛你們 好不好
聽哲哲買到515的國巨
愛哲哲就對了 是啊 好不好
來 OK 世界跟智原
比較牛皮一點啦
這次國巨反彈很弱 沒關係啦
環球晶 群聯好可惜
尾盤沒跟上
環球晶有拉起來啊
威剛如何
其實威剛
晶豪科都拉起來了
你不用擔心 好不好
好想再看哲哲跳舞 我沒有
請問哲哲美股23小時
會不會減少台日韓的成交量
當然不會啊 怎麼會
我們分析師很可憐 拜託
主管機關千萬不要
感覺好像還好
不要延長什麼台灣的交易時間
不要這樣好不好 我會累死
我每天已經工作十幾個小時
美股23小時
因為美股是世界中心嘛 沒關係嘛
台灣不要虐待自己
美股23小時
會不會減少台日韓股票資金的流量
不會啦
只是期貨的交易量會變多而已好不好
哲哲環球晶可以加碼嗎
1000元以下的環球晶都逮就捕
我們先講 我喝個水
我們先講我們的精材有沒有看到
今天拉起來有沒有看到
精材今天也拉起來了
一堆股票拉起來沒錯吧
國巨這樣拉
華新科這樣拉還不夠喔
3374精材這樣拉還不夠喔
有看到嗎
看一下我們的恭賀 來
導播來一下 好
8月25號禮拜二 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價開低走高翻紅
重新站回月季線之上
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺60%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
恭喜大家賺大錢
精材也拉起來
你告訴我誰在低檔的時候
最多活力給你
你真的要看我的節目
不然你撐不下去
這個行情真的很無聊
從1.5兆的成交量
到現在給你莫名其妙
到7000億 6000億
不是哲哲生龍活虎 你撐不下去
可是我跟你講
我講話是有邏輯的
我講這件事情就好了
我們先講兩件事情 來
今天頭版新聞就是
美國要砸1兆美元購債
我問大家一件事情
現在如果
你之前的30年期美債殖利率5.3%
如果你現在Fed利率也是5.3%
你購債有用嗎 沒用
不能講髒話或是不文雅的話
沒用
有幫我嗶起來嗎
沒有啦 我自己嗶起來
沒有用 沒有用啦
這個比較激動一點
我的意思是說 來
哪個分析師告訴你
他們現在很多人
要嘛就不解總經
不解總經的分析師你要看喔
你要看隨便你啦
崩盤的時候不用解總經喔
我跟你講 我們摩爾的分析師
基本上都會解總經
我告訴你分析師本來就要解總經
來 為什麼要解總經
解總經解的莫名其妙也沒意義啊
沒有意義啦
來 我告訴你這個事情
來 看一下
我做的這張圖
因為那時候不是說美債殖利率
有些新聞 看到華爾街有新聞
然後一些網紅跟你講的
2007年的時候美債殖利率是5.29%啦
所以造成泡沫啦
這是這20幾年來的一個紀錄啦
要突破了啦
美債殖利率這麼高 怎麼辦
殖利率成本這麼高 死定了
我說2007年的時候
金融海嘯的前一年
會戳破泡沫是因為Fed利率這麼高
不是美債殖利率
你現在美債殖利率這麼高
沒有關係
你美債殖利率我說
你跟美債殖利率怎麼樣
我講得很清楚啊
有沒有
2007年的時候
這是美債殖利率
都是差不多5.3%
可是Fed的利率差那麼多
有很大的操縱空間
怎麼樣很大的操縱空間
現在就買了一兆美元的美債
要買1兆美元購債有沒有看到
我請問你
如果是2007年你買1兆美元的購債
你可以把利率壓低下去嗎
不行 因為他基準利率就這麼高
他基準利率就是5.25%
懂不懂
他現在基準利率那麼低
所以他可以壓下去
他就是一個基準 你懂不懂
你知道他就是一個
銀行定存的一個利率的基準
是不是
你30年期的美債殖利率
你給我的利率還低於定存利率
那誰要買美債
所以那時候基準利率那麼高
是沒辦法
現在基準利率那麼低
然後美債殖利率那麼高
他可以壓得下去
以前那麼高 兩個都那麼高
壓不下去
哪個分析師跟你講這個東西
所以空間就很大嘛
所以1兆美元這樣救市下去
美國股市昨天本來要崩了
這個消息多少有支撐力道
哪個分析師跟你講這個東西
你只看我激動
你看我的肌肉
或者你看我激動
為什麼你不看我的腦袋
投資朋友 我跟別人不一樣
我再講一件事情
沒有分析師比我還了解AI
我每天都要問他
我每一件事都問他
我有時候想講
但是有些是商業秘密
我怕那些投顧業都學了
我不想教他們
但是我也不會去攻擊他們
我都祝福他們
我還是要跟很多同業講
他們不認同
我們真的有把餅做大
各個投顧業現在的營收
也比以前多好幾倍 是不是
我們沒有把餅做大嗎
有啊 以前大家
對分析師的印象是很不好
所以毀滅哲哲
並不會讓大家的業績變好
我敬告同業
而且還會讓自己業績變差
某一位張姓分析師
你自己的業績有比較好嗎
你大家都知道 看財報就知道
身體有比較好嗎
沒有 我希望他身體好
沒必要 早知如此何必這樣對我呢
可是我真的希望他們大家都好
真的 所以分析師你要慎選
真的要慎選
像哲哲這樣子慎選
不是我要臭屁 好不好 來
國巨好像快死掉了是不是
不會啦 台勝科也不錯
可是台勝科基本面沒有那個
其實台勝科跟合晶都是一樣 好不好
不想要鴻海太爛
不要鴻海太爛
你這樣聽了我會難過
可是鴻海真的不行的話要換 好不好
哲哲寶貝
ABF跌下去就會站不起來嗎
我要買低基期的
我不要買ABF載板
都已經從
我去年70元
被人家罵成這樣子
現在1000多元
你問我要不要買
我瘋了喔
是不是 來
我獲利滿多走掉了
3 400元走掉
夠了啦 70幾元撐3 400百元
來 嚴格來說我是買100多元
70幾元我記得也有叫人家
100元以下有叫人家買 來
所以有時候加碼很重要
來 我們來看一下
剛才有人說環球晶怎麼看
我再給你第二個新聞
不是第二個新聞
你看分析師很重要
有人報告會這樣寫嗎
根本就不會
很多現在人都不會寫這個報告
來 看一下
當掉了 沒有
來 等一下喔
好 可以了
這邊 畫面給我
來 這邊
環球晶市場訊號升級
你看環球晶2026年8月4號對不對
有沒有看到
這個月而已嘛 法說會是不是不好
法說會我記得有點跌嘛 對不對
他說訊號初期轉強嘛
非長約的現貨價格
現貨價格上漲喔
但長約還在洽談喔
通常是這樣子 一定是這樣子
我先談現貨
業界都這樣子
就現貨的價格嘛
然後約定的價格我不談 為什麼
我怎麼知道
這個矽晶圓漲真的 漲假的
我是客戶 我幹嘛答應你
所以我的現貨價格
我有點缺 我先跟你買
等到一定的時間的時候
OK
我感覺我明年也會缺貨
那我先跟你簽約再說嘛 是不是
所以非長約的價格上漲
但是長約洽談中
管理階層語氣保守
產線滿載
但是不知道產線滿載多久
這是8月4號而已喔
兩個禮拜
在SEMI論壇直接告訴你
轉正了啦 訊號大轉正了
現貨跟新長約價格雙雙向上
而且一漲價是接受雙位數漲價
徐秀蘭 這是高層
等了很久
董事長 總經理
等了很久 怎麼樣
現貨跟長約價格
我記得6吋 8吋 12吋矽晶圓
都漲了 基本上全部都上漲了
長約價格
還有兩個禮拜
8月4號到8月21號
17天的時間 兩個多禮拜
可以差這麼多
兩個多禮拜
市場訊號升級
長約價格本來不談的
本來不漲價的
全部都要談
而且一增加 雙位數
我看到你看不到的未來
那些投信跟著哲哲的屁股
沒有關係 我不是侮辱你們
要賺錢一起賺
有時候我也跟著你們買 沒差啊
或者有時候一起買
我其實不太喜歡跟人家買
就是我覺得我也認同就一起買
英雄所見略同 但我是領先者
為什麼 我就是要買低基期的
我就是要買600元台積電
我不去追高
我可以每天表演漲停板
只要不斷的追高
但是我不屑做這種事
有些人也會學我的講法
我不一定要賺這個錢
你們久了就知道
我真的不需要賺那些錢
我靠我自己賺也可以
我用我的能力告訴你
你告訴我 有誰這麼愛矽晶圓
我不要一會CPO強就講CPO
我不要一會航運股強就講航運股
我的中心主軸還是AI
就只有AI
沒有AI就BI BI啦
這個也是我公開講的啦
我告訴大家
所以從這個矽晶圓告訴你
哲哲真的看到人家看不到的未來
你看 美光跟人家簽十年長約
玩真的啦 美光認真的啦
你就以後美光會不會三星或誰
會不會想跟他簽
別人笑我太瘋癲 我笑他人看不穿
我要告訴你
AI會需求無遠弗屆
昨天奧特曼
昨天釋出的影片
開始往我講的
他講的就是這樣子
有地震耶
我剛才被嚇到了
有地震嗎
為什麼叫那麼大聲
他說將有強烈搖晃耶
可能等一下
震波可能會過來
我們等一下好不好
沒關係 我為你們燃燒生命
雖然我在16樓
剛才很大聲對不對
我想說我做了什麼事情
有地震嗎 你們哪邊的
報告一下
這個直播很刺激
有地震喔
6.6 哪邊
什麼怪聲音 我也嚇到
我是被他嚇到
我第一次有這樣叫
而且我用靜音模式耶 你知道嗎
來 新低量必有新低價
所以展開黑暗地獄之門
你不要嚇人家這個好不好 佛地魔
我也被手機嚇死了
重點是我第一次聽到
我剛才起雞皮疙瘩
害我流汗一下
不是 因為我剛很認真你知道嗎
我等一下要去收驚了啦
來了嗎
沒有啦 不要亂講話
微晃
那應該是很遠的地方
這個地震應該滿強的
我剛才講到哪個地方
等一下 我這個掉下來
我們靜待 讓子彈飛一回
我們暫停
不是暫停啦 就是
拉起來 好
大家跟我講一下 留言一下好不好
導播幫我看一下留言
導播幫我一一看留言 看一下
台中有感喔
那應該南部的喔
叫你地震就地震 不要亂講話
這個到時候
台北無感啦 有沒有
震央在綠島
綠島應該很危險
高雄很搖
所以說南部嘛 是不是
台中 台南啦 好不好
台北要開始震了嗎
哲哲一拍 台股大噴
哲哲一拍 地震是不是
不好意思
我剛才只是把腳抬起來而已
好啦 不要開這種玩笑
叫你地震就地震 不要鬧
結果大家都被手機嚇到
真的啊 我第一次耶
你是不是第一次
我記得我第一次手機叫耶
可以不要這樣子嗎
因為我都調靜音
哲神你不逃跑 我服了
我就是燃燒生命到最後一刻
你們會不會回去重看我的重播
我嚇到了
台東5.0喔
震央在台東喔
最近行情這麼震盪
請問下一步對策是怎麼樣
拉回就是買
來 明天台股要噴了
地震哲哲繼續講 沒受驚
你講清楚好不好
來 彰化有感覺
還好 沒事了
來 我真的燃燒生命好不好
我的手機比哲哲手機早10秒鐘
不是因為你的手機比我早10秒鐘
我跟你同一個時間
是因為直播會Lag 15秒
Lag 10到15秒對不對
這是我今天聽到比較好玩的笑話
沒關係 因為你們沒有直播過
不是你的手機比哲哲手機早10秒鐘
是因為手機會Lag 15秒
為什麼會Lag 15秒
有些要是突然脫衣服 脫光光
18禁的或者不雅的動作 不雅的語言
他可能會自動偵測
會把你的直播給卡掉
你懂我的意思嗎
所以直播一定要慢個15秒 好不好
為什麼 因為那個
這是以前在超級盃的時候你知道嗎
這個故事 超級盃
就是足球超級盃的時候
有沒有Janet Jackson跟Justin
跟大賈斯汀
跳一跳的時候
然後胸罩掉下來 露點了
露點了以後
那時候直播的時候
直播的時候沒有那種延後15秒
D-Live那種感覺
所以從此以後直播一定要
我雖然是直播
但會延後15秒
一看到露點了要卡 懂不懂
所以我剛才直播的時候
你會感覺我手機響得比較慢
沒有 其實跟你同一個時間
因為直播會延後15秒 好不好
哲哲怎麼懂那麼多
廢話 我不懂那麼多
我怎麼當分析師
隨便問我都知道歷史
好不好 OK嗎
而且人家講的
比如說主持人或什麼
那是事先Set好的梗
我不需要事先 好不好
要看的東西多
所以你要信我
重點是我看的東西多不重要
最厲害的是要預測未來
AI就是趨勢 懂不懂 來
哲哲連這個都知道
都知道好不好 來
哲哲不躲地震 觀眾怎麼躲
你們可以帶著手機躲 好不好
哲哲第三台救護車
不急 不急
第三台救護車我考慮了
不是現在
我最近剛卡1億好不好
哲哲沒有那麼有錢好不好
助理記得
第三台盡量就在南部 好不好
免得你們覺得我有政治傾向
沒有 都是台灣人
分什麼政治傾向
不要這樣講 我聽了很難過
我很討厭人家講我是藍的
或者是白的 或者是綠的
你懂不懂
我都是台灣人 不要分好不好
我覺得不要分
硬要分我是覺得
台灣人拜託
不要去美國 不要去日本
給他那個潑油
我們不要 真的有點尷尬
丟臉到國外去
但是我不是要批評人家
真的沒必要
都尊重每個人宗教信仰
跟政治信仰
來 扯遠了
一個地震真的要收驚
沒有啦 開玩笑 我是還好
我就是不逃避的男人 來
訊號轉正
你光CPO題材 你看一下
光CPO題材你看一下
你看投信買幾天
你看投信都在偷買
有沒有 投信開始買了
他不便宜
1張1000塊
投信在灌單有沒有看到
投信我看一下5483
5483沒那麼純
但是也開始在買了有沒有
買大於賣 有沒有
投信買大於賣
然後我們看3532
3532投信買很多
就他量而言買很多
都是投信在灌的
有沒有看到
300多塊還敢買有沒有看到
因為之前500多塊
台股NO.1
還有什麼
助理提醒我一下
我在考慮要不要台勝科再買一下
好不好 提醒我一下
因為投信有在買
所以你看 我告訴你一個集團
不是集團 一個族群
如果投信都不約而同這個時間買
代表什麼意思
代表是漲真的機率很高
為什麼
因為他們可能是去拜訪台勝科
台勝科也跟他講不錯
所以他去買
當然有些投信直接看線圖
當然也會找人去拜訪
可能我去拜訪什麼
我去拜訪那個環球晶
我去拜訪合晶 是不是
你發現到
我有各自拜訪的路線
但是得出來的結論怎麼樣
矽晶圓缺真的
當然缺啊
邊緣AI
就是你不是在AI伺服器運算這一塊
你在邊緣AI
我自己電腦可不可以也運算AI
也可以啊
類似這樣邊緣AI
不是在核心這樣叫邊緣AI
也需要先進製程
也需要成熟製程
那都會缺矽晶圓
還有我說記憶體
等到記憶體擴產的時候
你就知道多缺
我跟你講啦
今年的ABF載板
就是明年的矽晶圓 漲十倍
我跟你講2000元
為什麼我記憶體很想買又不想買
因為記憶體卡在本益比太低
有時候本益比太低
因為我昨天也在看了
彼得林區說的話
當然我自己也知道
有時候本益比太低不是好事
就市場認定它是景氣循環股
有時候比較難漲起來
不然我覺得記憶體
我覺得它現在還要一段時間吸收籌碼
就像國巨一樣
不像環球晶
它其實籌碼很單純 好不好
當然我覺得這些都是未來的趨勢
你看投信都在買
跟著哲哲屁股後面
不好意思 這樣講你們會不會生氣
表演 不要壓力大
我沒講針對哪個投信經理人
趕快一起買好不好
這個沒什麼不好
哲哲講在前面
你看這些東西
我們再講一下 來
我再喝個水一下
我們今天要臭屁一下我的期貨
期貨在這裡買 有沒有
我看它拉起來了
哲哲是不是帥氣 是
哲哲是不是幽默 是
哲哲是不是身材還不錯 是
哲哲是不是很久
講話講很久 是
0 哲哲我想不出來了
0 哲哲是不是凌晨12點
還在跟大家聊天 是
44490點進場多單
賺300點
這樣還敢賺 你看一下
恭喜 來 幫我念一下
好 8月25禮拜二 今天的簡訊
恭喜我們的期貨當沖多單
已經在44790點出場
成功獲利300點
恭喜大家賺大錢
我們期貨多單
已經在44790賺300點
我這個就是寶刀一出手
便知有沒有
這樣知道嗎
我來真的
所以我們再跟你講
來看一下做了很多AI圖
所以你看
環球晶最誇張
你要記得一件事
為什麼我要把這個擋起來
差17天可以
你要懂我的邏輯
我相信很多投信經理人了解
差17天 它是
其實中美晶 環球晶
為什麼大家喜歡他們
因為他們講話很老實
差17天是從保守預期
到明確確認漲價
而且一漲漲雙位數
一漲長約價格也準備要簽了
差17天可以變化這麼大
那你有沒有想過
如果差一個月 差兩個月
股價會差多大
再講一次 差17天從模糊不定
到現在非常明確
而且雙位數漲價
一個月 兩個月以後
股價會變化多大
基本面變化多大
這是真正的題材 拜託一下
我都說送分給你的
我最擅長就是挖掘低基期股票
我不要買那些漲上天邊的股票
就算群聯這樣跌下去
我反而開心
我為什麼今年績效那麼好
我就是不追高
不追 不追 不追
不 不 不
剪刀 石頭 布
我還是出布 就是不追
不 不 不
我不追 買低基期
光這個你看多厲害
這基本面很厲害
還有美國公債
美國財政部長做什麼事情
我都給你預告
我說這個太好了
他有操縱的空間
因為他的基準利率低
基準利率高怎麼壓下去
你壓得比基準利率低
誰要買美債 是不是
來 散戶縮手了
貨幣 M1B
M1B是什麼你知道嗎
M1B就是大概
包括現金 支票 存款
活期存款有沒有看到
M1B很簡單
M2就是M1B加上定存
聽不懂沒關係
M1B就是這些
全部可以隨時拿來買股票的
活存嘛 支票存款嘛 是不是
現金 是不是隨時可以買
是不是 M2是什麼
M2是比較固定的
M2是除了M1再加什麼
再加外幣存款
你外幣存款
台灣一天只能換50萬的
就是換50萬
如果台幣換成美金的話
我記得是50萬美金
是不是 1500萬嘛
大概1700萬
所以要換很麻煩
定期存款 定存也是要解約
大家想到解約要打8折
8折 8折 88折
打8折也是很麻煩
所以M2會比較麻煩
就是沒有準備馬上來投資股票的
所以你M2把定存改成M1B的時候
就代表這個數據會往上
代表這個準備要做股票了
你懂不懂 有沒有聽過一句話
人是英雄 錢是膽
有聽過嗎
這個意思就是說
你如果想當英雄的話
你的錢就是你最好的膽量 為什麼
我要是富二代
我不是
很多人一直覺得我是富二代 我不是
所以我是力求
我現在投資是這樣
力求不傷身 再求療效 跟吃藥一樣
先求不傷身 再求療效
所以為什麼選低基期
先求不大賠 再求大賺
就這樣子
我要是富二代
人是英雄 錢是膽嘛
我隨便衝啊
反正爸爸還會給我錢
爸爸再給我錢
衝啊 衝啊 當沖衝衝衝
是不是
所以人是英雄 錢是膽
有錢的時候就敢衝
台灣股市有錢的時候也敢衝啊
M1B這很重要
很久沒講這個東西
因為這個死亡交叉滿明顯的 來
看一下 應該有死亡交叉
輝達財報什麼時候
今天禮拜二 明天再講好了
反正輝達財報我告訴你
就是不錯啦 好不好
看一下輝達財報
等一下喔
來 等一下喔 這邊有沒有看到
死亡交叉了啦 有沒有
上個月死亡交叉 為什麼交叉
因為現在聽到
什麼借錢是幾%
3%還4% 還是5%
券商為什麼 我覺得這是好事
如果現在太熱 上個月太熱了
你知道 包含我們摩爾
其實每一家投顧
上半年1到6月的營收
基本上都突破去年整年營收
誇不誇張 行情很熱
所以你把它降下來好啊
就是因為降下來 冷一下
大家才不會去借錢買股票
你降下來 我覺得這是好
以前如果這樣子 我會說不好
所以現在量在縮了 因為死亡交叉
這是死亡交叉
資金面的死亡交叉
好不好 OK嗎
這M1B橘色是7.34有沒有看到
M1B就是他比較靈活 你知道嗎
就像技術線型的比較短天期的
比較靈活
所以他急速下滑 為什麼
因為有些人第一個是虧掉錢嘛
第二個是現金 我不爽了啦
我拿去買外匯了 我不高興
我拿去買定存了
所以M1B大幅度下滑 有沒有
M1B大幅度下滑
然後M2本來就比較慢
因為M2有包含M1B 這是M2
我剛才講M2有包含M1B加定存
M1B沒有定存
急速下滑
那他一把錢存到定存的時候就下滑很快
是不是 你知道嗎 這個跟大家講
M2也有下滑一點點 好不好
資金供給量減少了
還有一些是借錢來的嘛
所以整個M2慢慢下滑了
大家不借錢了 還錢了
所以資金寬鬆度也變差了 你懂不懂
這代表資金流出股市
Understand OK嗎
所以沒有關係 好不好
無量出飆股 慢慢來
你們不要等到1點多兆再來
哲哲你好厲害 哲哲你好猛
那時候可能已經48000 50000了
年底見啦 我告訴你
反正今年年底你就知道
我多厲害 50000點
那時候就賺2000多萬了
第三台救護車我答應你們
就是南部嘛 好不好
盡量就是南部 好不好 OK嗎
現在我們那個 哲哲
剛捐而已 第二台
第二台還在湊錢
我買了一億的那個0050
年底那個尾款還是要3 400萬
我們不是那個
我知道有分析師去捐復康巴士
我覺得他很厲害
某個分析師我覺得不錯
人也很好 很善良
可是他們是用公司名義
我是用個人名義
我公司 你懂我的意思嗎
公司名義你還可以再節稅
你懂不懂
譬如說我1000萬的淨利
我直接拿去捐救護車了
就不用繳20%的營所稅了
你懂不懂
可是不是 我們是先繳完營所稅的時候
我拿到錢再去捐
而且我不是復康巴士
我沒有攻擊別人
我講的是我們的救護車更貴
要500萬
一般的車子不是那麼便宜
你懂不懂 好不好
還有人叫我捐消防車
消防車應該要1000萬
我問一下好不好
我做不到的
可是我跟大家講
我真的期許我這輩子捐22台
捐1億以上
我慢慢的一年一年捐
我們去年捐的
今年年底12月桃園 好不好
這個跟大家講
而且我跟大家講
其實你去問就知道
到時候他可能會受訪
就是幫我們處理救護車的
我是要求是今年要完成
我想今年的事情
今朝有酒今朝醉 今日事今日畢
OK嗎 這個跟大家講
哲哲寶貝怎麼看待
未來5到10年的房市
不用看 以後房子除非你有剛性需求
你就是要住 不然不要
房地產3%
你知道常常看那些什麼租霸
真的沒必要
就不要買 你懂不懂
真的不要買 好不好
除非有剛性需求
台灣房地產上不去也下不來
因為成本太重 裝潢成本太重
建設成本太重 你懂不懂
然後很難賺回錢
你要租給人家3%
還要地價稅 是不是
賣掉還要土地增值稅
地價稅 房屋稅沒人要付
還要選房客
你太累了 是不是
應該要用公司名義捐
我就想用我的名字捐
公司名義我再考慮一下
來 台股NO.1不逃避的男人
你都這樣講 智原 世界
你真的很厲害
哲哲寶貝是台股不逃避的男人
然後講這兩檔股票
我能不解釋嗎
我不解釋我就逃避了 來
好膽你別走 智原
我跟你講智原就差不多成本
所以我最近沒叫人家加碼智原
他就是大多頭的時候
找不到股票的時候買一下
問題是他ASIC題材
還沒有那麼快 你懂不懂
當然TPU也算是ASIC一種
但是他就是這個
還沒有跑到這一塊
他算很邊緣 不是邊緣AI
他算很邊緣這一塊
就是他現在發酵還沒拿到
你懂不懂
但是還是比航運股好
我講航運股是
航運股就不算AI
人家還跟AI擦到邊
只是現在還沒有賺到
就像矽晶圓一樣
就像2023年
2023年我就看好ABF載板
結果漲一陣子以後
到3年後才爆發
我的缺點就是看太遠
真的我的缺點看太遠
所以講長期我很厲害
吃長崎蛋糕我也很厲害
長崎的蜂蜜蛋糕滿好吃的你知道嗎
冷笑話
反正長期我很厲害
我們5年 4年內10萬點
我覺得4年 甚至3年就有機會10萬點
你記得我講這句話
沒給你唬爛的
可是我是合格分析師
來 本資料僅供參考
我每天要跟你講
你們要穩的 拜託 不要找我
好不好 我是合法分析師
好不好 投資有漲有跌 有賺有賠
我不缺這個業績
要去找別人
OK 我是說真的
主管機關也是希望我們
常常講這些東西
提醒大家風險
我跟大家講 人在做天在看
5347世界先進怎麼看
重點是現在沒有資源
所以鴻海為什麼拉不起來
就少了1兆 你知不知道 1兆耶
錢就這樣子不夠多啊
我跟你講要不是少這1兆
我跟你講
環球晶這個早就噴到1600
國巨早就噴到7 800
你要趁現在便宜買
你再想想看
2022年的4年前
台積電380耶
還有一堆人笑我
他們都笑我耶
你要開心 股市就是這樣
行情悶的時候看我的節目 懂不懂
我們粉絲就是這樣來的好不好
少子化 房子會慢慢下來
對啊 因為大家
很多人繼承財產
這個用膝蓋想就知道
你要買就要買交通方便
台北市就買捷運附近的 好不好
雖然捷運超過10分鐘
你就不要買
你本來就有了
我不是要批評你
你住得爽 住得開心就好
反正你本來就要住的也沒差
如果你真的要投資
那你一定要買交通方便的
我是不建議啦 好不好
你有錢呢
比如像周杰倫這麼有錢嘛 是不是
去小巨蛋那邊附近買嘛 是不是
人家有錢到沒處花
當然可以買嘛 你懂不懂
資產配置嘛
怎麼知道哪一天
會不會房地產又起來
你沒有到那麼有錢
你沒有動輒幾十億
沒有十億以上
你就是自用就好
十億 超過十億
你可以置產 什麼叫置產
因為你不知道
什麼時候房地產會起來
那你可以買一些 這樣懂不懂
哲哲太棒了 愛你 愛你很聰明
謝謝 我也愛你們 好不好
中美晶回200還要很久嗎
看量啦 OK
帆宣是否能脫手
帆宣 其實有些股票就是
他再不動我也想換
我想換比較火的 好不好
哲哲說功率元件
太多股票 不看了
聯發科就被搶單
不要說被搶單
他的對手被搶單
那個新聞消息出來以後
代表TPU沒有很難生產
麥格理就害到你了 好不好 來
一直買美債
股票不是就一直起不來
什麼意思
他們喔 這是兩碼子事情
財政部可以印鈔票
這個邏輯不對喔
他可以平白無故印鈔票
QE就是這樣子
一直QE股市還不是起來
通貨膨脹股票也會起來 OK嗎
這個我要花比較多時間
就不講了 好不好 來
哲哲寶貝 鴻海講一下
功率元件沒有啦
功率元件量很少我不講
量很少 不夠我塞牙縫我不講
我還是講一下功率元件 2481
功率元件或這些相關的
投信你看也沒在這邊著墨
這個外資看起來有時候是假外資
這是假外資 本土大戶
你去看我的 你看
我看一下 順便看合晶
合晶還好
可是你看3532台勝科
現在投信沒什麼錢
因為現在大家沒買什麼基金
沒有ETF 行情沒那麼好
6488環球晶 你看
都在偷買有沒有看到
哪一個族群現在投信一直在買
5483中美晶
中美晶也有在買
稍微少一點
因為中美晶沒有那麼純的矽晶圓
他靠的是環球晶
這個族群基本上都在買
我們再看一下 還有什麼
2408南亞科我們看一下
投信也買很凶 好不好
還有我們看一下
8299群聯
我自己有點想再加碼華邦電
因為基期比較低
再讓我想一下好不好
再讓我想一下
還有什麼 沒有了
群聯 華邦電
助理明天問我一下華邦電
或有一些新會員
助理要提醒我
華邦電新會員的話
我要想一下好不好
40幾 我今天那麼激動才43分
差不多快結束了好不好
今天為什麼覺得錄影
錄得比平常久但是沒有
因為地震的關係 好不好 來
今天聽哲哲的話拉回就買
今天馬上賺 對嘛 好不好
考慮力積電嗎
力積電 黃董不在了
我就比較不想買了
比較感傷啦 好不好
我蠻喜歡他的
你看一個人很負責任
下市了 是不是
可以拍拍屁股走了
沒有 很認真負責 好不
瑤池金母買聯電
聯電本來就應該
就不錯了好不好
航運股怎麼看
我就說航運股基本上不會
如果下個月這個時候還能漲
那才叫真的漲了啦
那是漲假的 不是漲假的
你看今天又殺下去了
這個主力 中實戶就一波到底
誰都知道8月行情好
誰都知道
我就說萬聖節 聖誕節
是不是這些開始 這些節日
10月 11月 12月
都有一些節日
所以一定會送這些禮物的
運送這些禮物的一波到底
這跟AI有關係嗎
我就說我現在不想買
跟AI沒有關係的 好不好
摺疊手機我倒是會買
到時候我給大家買的情況 好不好
如我所料
我說摺疊手機是用Touch ID
我說我現在比較喜歡我的
比如說你的照片或什麼東西 好不好
還是可以
還是可以保護好
APP有時候沒鎖住
習慣的APP還是可以點進去
現在要Touch ID比較麻煩
我可能兩支都會買
一支就是買新的
不是摺疊手機
一支摺疊手機 好不好
第一時間買 好不好
這個跟大家講 來
航運股不要再追了
很多分析師在節目上講
分析師有分兩種
一種是本來就看好的
當然航運股本來就看好的老師很少
另外一種就是我講的老投顧
其實現在很多投資朋友
很多會員是水深火熱
我去講航運股要幹什麼
我不懂 這不是我的習慣
我不是要批評人家
我講的是事實
我就專注在我新買的被動元件
國巨 華新科
甚至我考慮再買
禾伸堂或這些股票 是不是
我原本的矽晶圓
我買得開開心心就好了
到一倍你們通通都獲利 是不是
這個我跟大家講好不好
所以我不是那種
我是很老派 但我不是老投顧
我的做法反而很新穎
我就是先求不傷身 再求療效
這種行情反而讓我今年行情特別好
OK嗎
鴻海講一下 鴻海沒講嗎
你們都叫我寶貝了 真的是 來
鴻海這個今天有下影線
鴻海就沒量嘛
沒量怎麼辦 灌不下去
他是大樹 你知不知道
你拿一盆水澆他也沒有用 你懂嗎
華新科到300元嗎
我們看一下華新科到300元
300元不難好不好
不要開玩笑 之前都320
華新科當然有機會
我都說國巨有機會700元
華新科應該有機會
400元應該不難
華新科跟華邦電
都考慮再進場
助理明天提醒我一下
最後那個輝達財報有沒有看到
輝達財報Q3 下一季
2.36 我覺得會再提高
1037會提高 為什麼
我的東西漲價15% 你要不要買
當然要買
我跟你講 腦袋越聰明的人
來 我再講一次
奧特曼給你最大的東西是
他已經認同技術到位了
剩下是串接API
我就說任何一個會寫程式的人
都知道我講的是對的
其實你只要會串接
你稍微修改他的程式 他的語音
他現在服務態度
就是我語音客服用AI客服
不用真人客服
絕對可以取代你
而且你分不出來
最明顯就是一個
去年的時候你們相信嗎
你媽媽開始看AI短劇
我媽媽跟我講他現在都在看AI短劇
男的很帥 女的很美
他說我的朋友都在看
老人家現在都接受度很高了
很恐怖耶
現在年輕人都在AI短劇
去年你能想像這件事情嗎
我跟你講 你現在沒有辦法想像AI客服
以後就會覺得OK
所以他難的是
AI短劇反而簡單 想一想就好
AI客服是這樣
我要在地申請 我要在地化
你這家公司需要什麼需求
每一家公司要的AI客服是不一樣
我只要串接你每一家公司
我就有利潤
他講的是這一段
沒有人聽得懂 我聽得懂
我一直在想怎麼做生意 你懂不懂
怎麼轉化成EPS
這需要時間發酵
等到發酵的時候
你們才知道AI投資是有回報
廢話 當然有回報
那些人只會看數字
都看過去的數字
那個很遜的分析師 懂不懂
華爾街有些分析師也不是特別厲害
他要串接這些程式
很多無遠弗屆的應用
都可以用
這個我跟大家講好不好 來
財報出來隔天就烙賽
不用擔心啦 還有機會好不好
今年那斯達克ETF
求求你講解一下
我求求你
要不要考慮參加我的會員一下
你每天求求我
不是會員求什麼 來
要找我嗎 研究AI客服
你現在就可以創業啦
你可以找每一家
比如說每一個早餐店也可以創業
電話OK以後 怎麼幫他下那個
就是接電話以後
也不用接電話
他自己接起來
怎麼幫你下單就好了 對不對
哲哲我錯了 沒撿940的環球晶
美國人不會做股票 有嗎 來
富邦AI客服電話
那個還算很假的
不是真的很強
以前的AI客服跟現在的AI客服
完全沒得比 好不好
還要一段時間
串接還要一段時間好不好
那最後也跟大家講
我們現在幾分了
49要結束了
我們現在三大問題看有沒有講
貨幣供給死亡交叉是好不是壞
就股市不是好
但就把股市澆一盤冷水
讓大家不要那麼多融資
不要像韓國股市暴漲暴跌
我覺得反而是好
中長期反而是好 因為之前太熱了
量能依舊不到700億 何時回歸
問神
遲早回歸 我只能這樣跟你講好不好
等到48000的時候你就看到了
台股拉快千點翻紅可以樂觀嗎
可以樂觀
更確定4萬點我認為不會破
我認為啦
這個答案都跟大家講了 好不好
今天股票也都講了很多
股票很強
好不好 還有什麼
該講的都講了
群聯也是一樣 好不好
8299群聯
其實這個股票還能這樣拉
你還看不懂
能這樣拉 一堆股票這樣拉
漲真的啦 不會破4萬了
差不多打個7折就可以買
一堆股票還在打7折
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師好不好
拜託一下 記得我們的IG
不要用什麼
IG Threads好像我的對話用截圖
我沒有什麼截圖
截圖還告訴你要加入什麼LINE不LINE
你懂不懂 一定是你問我
我沒有什麼這樣跟你講
我不會主動招攬生意
沒有 我不需要
網路上那些主動招攬LINE的
那都是假的好不好
你要加你自己加
我不會去主動行銷
IG跟threads s178178
或者LINE@s178
想要加入會員也可以最快的方式
來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
記得嗎 那時候我講600元台積電
被很多人笑
跌到400元 跌到500元
我看到的是機會 你看到的是滅亡
不是這樣子
這次我又看到機會
你要不要跟我一起來賺大錢
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
今年台灣股市就5萬點以上
我認為就是5萬點以上
我們一起來賺大錢
趕快加入我們的行列
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
Byebye